hey this is pressed Elle Walker and
you're watching mind your decisions
consider the following diagram the arc
centred at O is a quarter circle find
the simplest formula for the radius of
the circle in terms of a B and C I read
that richard fineman
missed this problem at first even great
minds can get tripped up can you figure
it out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
a solution so let me first go over the
wrong answer but a common mistake people
make the common mistake is to use the
Pythagorean theorem let R equal the
radius of the circle we can then write
that R minus a is one length of this
rectangle and R minus C is the other
side of this rectangle we then have a
right triangle with sides R minus ay R
minus C and a hypotenuse B by the
Pythagorean theorem the quantity R minus
a squared plus the quantity R minus C
squared is equal to B squared will you
men expand this out into a second degree
equation in R we can then solve for R
using the quadratic formula and only
retaining the positive square root to
get a positive value for the radius we
end up with the following complicated
formula for R in terms of a B and C so
this is a valid formula but it's not the
simplest formula so it's the wrong
answer to this puzzle so how can we
figure it out the trick is to notice B
is the diagonal of a rectangle if we
again let R equal the radius of the
circle the trick is to consider what is
the length of the other diagonal of this
rectangle well if we draw the other
diagonal
we'll notice that it's exactly the
radius of the circle so R is also equal
to the length of a diagonal of this
rectangle but since the diagonals of a
rectangle are equal to each other this
means we have a very simple formula we
must have R is equal to B and that's the
correct answer did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free inspire and build confidence for
people around the world and they already
have over a hundred million views with
your help we can share the beauty of
mathematics and make the world a better
place please subscribe for free to get
the newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos email me a
puzzle or topic presh at mind your
decisions calm if you so choose you can
read my books which are linked in the
video description and you can support me
on patreon to earn exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support